sin duda en este segundo discurso del
estado de la unión después de dos años
en la casa blanca lo que va a hacer el
presidente Joe es Resaltar los logros de
estos primeros dos años de
administración logros en cuanto a lograr
haber frenado esa crisis inflacionaria
que vivía el país el año pasado logros
en cuanto a lograr que los estudiantes
pues puedan sentir un poco más esa ayuda
de parte del gobierno para no tener que
responder rápidamente a las obligaciones
financieras que tenían de cara
precisamente a esta pandemia y
obviamente el tema del techo de la deuda
será uno de los temas principales que
abordará el presidente también lo hará
hablará sobre el tema de Ucrania pero lo
que ya muchos analistas están diciendo
acá en Estados Unidos es que en general
lo que va a terminar de hacer el
presidente es presentar el caso
presentar su propuesta de cómo sería un
gobierno de Joe biden después de El 2024
es decir presentar su caso de
para dentro de dos años esto de cara ya
a pues las campañas que ha venido
haciendo ya su posible contrincante
Donald Trump en las elecciones del 2024
Así que resaltará sus temas en logros
económicos resaltará como el desempleo
ha estado en niveles mínimos bajos
récord y resaltará obviamente ese
control inflacionario que ha sido una de
las propuestas principales que ha
querido lograr el presidente en los
últimos dos años será después de su
discurso la la ex jefe de prensa de
Donald Trump
la Que responda en representación del
partido republicano frente a lo que diga
hoy a las nueve de la noche desde acá
desde el Capitolio de Estados Unidos
frente al pueblo estadounidense
Cristóbal contanos Cómo llega
políticamente biden a su segundo
discurso sobre el estado de la unión y
aprovecho para hacerte otra pregunta qué
detalles se conocen ya del evento algo
que haya trascendido
Sí definitivamente es de Resaltar que la
seguridad en el perímetro del Capitolio
aquí en Capitolio ha sido bastante
intensa de hecho han vuelto a poner las
mismas vallas que pusieron hace dos años
cuando simpatizantes de Donald Trump Se
tomaron el Capitolio es decir las vallas
negras que están
alrededor de el perímetro de El
Capitolio y pues llega a este segundo
discurso del estado de la unión con una
popularidad baja De hecho el ABC ayer
publicaron una encuesta de cómo los
estadounidenses
63% de ellos cree que es el presidente
no ha logrado y no ha hecho mucho
durante sus primeros dos años de
gobierno solo el 36% decía que
efectivamente el presidente había
logrado temas significativos Pero como
se los demócratas se defienden diciendo
que muchas de las políticas que los
primeros dos años del presidente que él
quiso empezar a implementar se van a ver
en su tercer y cuarto año de gobierno si
es el caso Pues sería muy favorable de
Cara a la intención de reelección que
como ya lo decíamos pues muchos están
diciendo que hoy a las nueve de la noche
será cuando el presidente haga el caso
para presentar su campaña reelección su
interés de reelegirse en el 2024